The following content is
provided under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help
MIT OpenCourseWare
continue to offer high-quality
educational resources for free.
To make a donation or
view additional materials
from hundreds of MIT courses,
visit MIT OpenCourseWare
at ocw.mit.edu.
GANG CHEN: OK, I wish you
all had a good weekend.
And just a recap
of last lecture--
it's a little bit extra
than last lecture--
but to say what we
solved is a problem
for heat conduction along a
two-dimensional, or thin, film.
And the Boltzmann equation,
reading for the deviation
function g, g is f minus f0.
So g is f minus f0.
And we say g because the
boundary in the y direction,
so there are constraints
changing g in the y direction.
So we have the cosine theta--
cosine theta is
the axial direction
of the phonon propagation.
And so we have, on the left-hand
side is a function of y.
And then, on the right-hand
side, it's a function of x.
The f0, because I
have f0 for phonon
is exponential
[INAUDIBLE] kt minus 1.
So t is a function of x.
Because I would consider
heat conduction along
the x direction.
And if you do electron
transport, which
we didn't do last
time, you have to keep
this term, the fourth term.
And that's one we
did in chapter 6,
the thermoelectric transport.
We traded both terms.
But see, the point
is if you look
at transport along
the x direction
and on the right-hand side
is a function of x only.
So I have a first-order
differential equation
for the deviation function
in the y direction
with right-hand
side is x dependent.
So because of that, the right
hand is essentially constant.
Because the left-hand
side is a function of y.
So when I did the integration,
I find the heat flux.
And what I'm given here is more
than I show in the last lecture
because this solution
is a Fuchs-Sondheimer--
Fuchs-Sond, I checked
the name, heimer--
solution.
and Fuchs-Sondheimer
originally solved
for the electron transport.
So this were, in the original
paper, electric conductivity
ratio of the thin film divided
the bulk is, say, 1 minus.
So it's reduced.
And this reduction is this
integral mu is cosine theta.
So it's 0 to 1.
And the p is a
specularity parameter--
p specularity parameter.
So if it's p equals
1, it's a specular.
P equals 0 is a diffuse.
So you can say if the
specular 1 minus p is 0,
so it's more like a waveguide.
There's no reduction if
it's a specular interface.
But the p equals 0 is diffuse,
so you will get reduction
in the thermal conductivity,
or electric conductivity,
if the interface scattered
electron-phonon diffusely.
But say it has been,
actually, really difficult
to say, what is this value of p?
And so far, the
best model people
use was still result that
derived by Ziman in 1950s.
And this p is related
to the surface roughness
and the wavelengths of
the phonon or electron.
So it's an exponential function.
And in fact, you see in
the front it's 16 pi cubic.
So that's a pretty large number.
Typically, in optics, when
people say a surface is rough,
or it's a specular, for
optically smooth surface,
its typical roughness is less
than 1/10 of the wavelength.
So you can say if the
roughness is less than 1/10
of the wavelength, this
p is getting close to--
this one, when it's very
small, is close to 1.
That's specular.
So this is a
Fuchs-Sondheimer solution.
And that's the for the
electrical and thermal
conductivity along a film.
And then we assume that
the length of this film
is very long.
So if you go to look
at the literature,
there are a lot of
papers published
on measuring thermal
conductivity of thin films
or nanowires.
And there are also
refined model of wires
of different cross-section,
whether it's circular
or whether it is a rectangle.
And the people have tried to
solve the Boltzmann equations.
And I mentioned that
in the last lecture,
even now, there are still some
results on the wires, possibly,
and people still
writing what could
be deviation from the Fuchs
and the Sondheimer solution.
And historically,
this is Casimir.
What Casimir did is,
really, he explained that
without solving
Boltzmann equation--
just no internal scattering,
you have rough surface--
and he say, OK, if you
have a rough surface
because the scattering
is diffused, so you have,
effectively, reduction in the
mean free path of the heat
carrier of the phonons.
And with that, he
was able to explain
why thermal conductivity
at low temperature
is proportional
to specific heat.
The mean free paths are
limited by the sample
size and the low temperature.
[INAUDIBLE] the thermal
conductivity ones that
are receiving gamma.
So when the mean free
path is a sample size,
it is proportional
to the specific heat,
which is t cubic.
So this is the Casimir
[INAUDIBLE] started.
So that's last lecture is film
conduction along the film.
Just one more comment.
You actually could say
that recently, there
are some paper on the thermal
conductivity of carbon
nanotubes.
And it turns out that
because the thermal nanotube
or the mean free
path is even longer
than the length of
the tube, so there
is additional sizing factor
at the two ends of the tube.
And what are we going
to do in today's lecture
is look at the other
direction, so heat conduction
perpendicular.
Let's say transport
perpendicular to film.
And if I look at
now the problem is,
and if I have a
temperature difference,
I have to be a
little bit ambivalent
at this stage, what's this
temperature really mean.
So I have a Te1, Te2 in the
thickness direction of a film.
And this is my y.
And again, I have
the mean free path is
could be longer than
the film thickness.
And then what's my effective
thermal conductivity?
And you can ask the
same question-- what's
my electrical conductivity?
And also, there's solution for
radiation, photon transport,
all those under
the same equation.
And I write down the Boltzmann
equation on the relaxation time
approximation.
So here, I have vy df dy
equals minus f minus f0 divided
by tau.
Because in this case, my
equivalent temperature
changes as a function of y.
So T is effectively
a function of y.
And f0 now, through the
temperature dependence,
exponential h bar
omega kT minus 1.
So you can say,
well, the difference
from the previous problem
is in the previous problem,
the relaxation time
is a function of x,
but the size effect
happens in the y direction.
Now my temperature
is a function of y,
and the size happen
in the same direction.
So my solution will
be more complicated
than the previous one.
And let's solve this problem.
And I will first do vy, again,
say any phonon transport
direction-- let's say
along this direction--
and the angle to the
y direction is theta.
So I will do this vy
is v cosine theta.
And v times tau I will normalize
against the mean free path.
So mean free path
is v times tau.
And I define a
non-dimensional variable eta
equals y over mean free path.
And in the previous
one, I could say
equals d over mean free path.
So that's normalized
to the thickness.
But this is an arbitrary
coordinate of y.
And if I do this, I write
the Boltzmann equation now
into mu, which is cosine theta.
Mu equals cosine theta that's
the direction of cosine.
And I have df dy plus f, I move
to the right-- not y, d eta--
the mean free path
now is v times tau.
So say eta is y
over mean free path.
So I non-dimensionalize
my equation.
On the right-hand
side, then, I have f0.
Remember, f0 is a function of
T, and T is a function of y.
I do not know that T. So now,
if I say the function of y
is also a function of
eta, so I have the f
is a function of eta.
F0 is also a function of eta.
Now, this equation is
a little bit harder
to solve than the previous one.
Because in the previous
one, the right-hand side
is a function of x.
The left-hand side
is a function of y.
Now, in the current one, both
left- and right-hand sides
are a function of eta.
And to solve this, the
first-order differential
equation, the trick
you do is, first,
you solve homogeneous equation--
eta df d eta plus f equals 0.
And here, you'll
find out this one
gives you f either is a
function of C exponential
minus eta over mu.
That's the solution for
homogeneous equation
when the right-hand side is 0.
And now, when the
right-hand side
is a function of eta
itself, you change
that C into an unknown function
you want is a function of eta.
So that's the standard
way of solving.
Now, rather than
say it's a constant,
say it's a function of eta.
You substitute this back
into the original equation.
You'll find out that
this term will drop out.
So what I have is mu
exponential eta mu dC d eta
equals f0, which is
a function of eta.
So this, when you substitute
this back into the differential
equation, this term drops.
The other term-- you can take a
derivative of this-- also drop.
The C term I cannot,
so it's there.
And now, because this
is a function of eta,
this is a function of
eta, so I can integrate.
So what I have is C itself.
dC, d eta equals f0, which
is a function of T eta--
that's a function of T--
and y over mu
exponential eta mu.
So I integrate.
I will get a C is C integrate--
another integration constant.
That depends on where I start.
So this is my eta 0 to eta
and 1 over mu exponential eta
prime and f0 eta
prime d eta prime.
So this is my solution
for this constant, which
is now no longer constant.
It's a function of eta.
And that's my solution.
And I combine this C
back into the original,
my solution for f eta.
But it's also a
direction function of mu
is C0 exponential
minus eta over mu.
That's this term.
Now, this term is also
multiplied into this term.
So what I have, because if this
y is integrated at eta prime,
so I can put that in.
So what I have is eta 0 to eta
1 over mu exponential minus eta
minus eta prime
mu f0 d eta prime.
So that's my general solution
for this original differential
equation.
You see that I didn't go
to find the deviation.
I just solved f directly.
And for the previous
problem, this one,
I used a division function.
But you don't have to.
You can still solve f directly.
You get the same result. It's
just a math book difference.
And again, I need to now use
the boundary condition to solve
for C0 and for each mu.
Now, for the
problem, each mu, mu
is cosine theta so that
for each theta, I have,
say, a different origin.
So for theta between
0 to 90 degree.
I have y equals 0.
This surface, if it's
diffuse, the temperature Te1
that goes out is isotropic.
And then, for 90
degree to 100 degree,
it's actually coming
from this surface.
And again, say, it's diffuse.
The temperature that
goes out is Te2.
This is what I call
emitted temperature.
So I go to do the condition
where eta equals 0.
So I start with eta 0 also at 0.
And this one drops out.
So what I have is f for mu is
less than 1 larger than 0--
that's 0 to 90 degree--
f eta mu is f0 Te1
exponential minus eta
to mu plus 0 to eta 1 over mu
exponential minus eta minus eta
prime over mu f0 d eta prime.
So unfortunately,
the difficulty is
this is almost the simplest
heat conduction problem.
It becomes very involved.
So this is the solution
for 0 to mu to 1.
I will put it a positive.
That's from bottom up,
forward propagating.
And similarly, for 90 degree to
180 degree, I have a solution.
For 90 to 180, so
mu is negative 1
and to 0, that's theta less
than, say, 180 degree, larger
than 90 degree, so backward
propagating from top surface
to down.
And my solution, f
prime eta mu, then you
would say f Te2, that's the
corresponding Bose-Einstein
distribution for
the phonons that
are coming into the domain
with a current temperature Te2.
So this is f0 Te2.
And exponential xi
minus eta over mu, this
is the effective
boundary effect.
Here is eta our mu.
It's negative.
It's exponential decay.
So what it says is if
my phonon is propagating
in this direction from the
boundary at this point,
because of scatter, it decays.
And that distance, the
decay that is exponential,
xi minus eta--
so that's really d minus
y, so that's this section.
And divided by cosine,
divided by mu is cosine theta.
So that's this distance.
So it's really because
mean free path,
so it's how much distance
travel over mean free path
exponential.
That's the decay because
they scatter out.
The boundary terms get scattered
and lost to the internal.
And then the last term
is xi to et and the 1
over mu exponential minus--
here, I have to be careful
because this is xi to eta,
so any d eta prime term, I have
to make sure this is a decay.
So I have eta minus eta prime.
That will be-- wait,
let me see whether it's
positive or negative.
So any term in between this
will be negative, this negative.
I should have another
negative sign in the front
and the f0 eta prime.
So this is how I
look at the equation
while I see whether my
solution is reasonable.
What I have here is I'm
looking at a certain point--
this point-- in space.
I look at the distribution
in this specific direction.
And what it comes--
one part is coming from
the wall, the boundary.
And that part of the
exponential is scattered out.
So that's the first term.
That's the decay term.
This term is decaying.
The outer term is,
along the path,
every point is a ray scatter
into this direction, like, say,
emission, an emission
into this direction.
So because of this,
I have contribution.
The contribution from this
point, that's f eta the prime--
f0 eta prime--
that's regenerated.
And the distance is
here, the difference.
So this is a regenerated phonon.
And this is the distance
divided by cosine theta, so
the real distance.
The y direction
coordinate, the y by cosine
say that that's the real
distance between this source
point and the point
I'm interested in.
And again, during this travel,
there is a scattering out.
So that's why they
exponent I have
to make is make sure
this exponent at the end
is negative eta minus eta prime.
Because this is eta xi.
So the eta prime is
between eta and xi.
So this is negative.
And mu is negative.
So I put the negative sign.
That should be my
correct solution.
You can go to actually
check the mathematics.
So now I have the
distribution function.
And my challenge is,
remember, this one, f0,
is a function of [INAUDIBLE].
I do not know.
It's inside the integral.
And what I have is a
non-local transport.
It's not like the Fourier's
law of heat conduction
where q equals minus k dt dx.
You see this is a
local transport.
Because the heat flux is
proportional to local gradient.
It doesn't depend on
quantity other place.
Of course, they are all coupled.
But local flux is only
proportional local gradient.
What I have here is
the flux at this point
depends on every point
along the trajectory.
That's why I have the
integral-- path integral-- here.
So this is the problem
when you go through nano.
Your transport becomes
coupled, and it's non-local.
And now, once I have f, I can
solve for my flux same way
q equals 1 over v. You sum up
all polarization, kx, ky, kz,
and vy, h bar omega f.
That's always the
starting point when
we try to find out what's
the [INAUDIBLE] flux.
Here, it's the full heat flux.
Again, charge flux, momentum
flux, this is how we start.
We sum up all possible modes--
quantum mechanical
or classical modes.
And together, they--
and, of course,
given the quantity h
bar omega, h [INAUDIBLE]
carry, quantum state carry,
and the group velocity.
So if you do this and you see we
have to convert this summation
into integration.
And I will actually split
this into two terms--
positive term and negative term.
And positive term are the
ones that goes forward.
Negative terms are going
from the outer boundary
going downward.
And then we can look at
what the expression after I
convert this into from
summation into integration.
So positive term is
actually 0 to pi d phi.
So this is-- again,
I'm changing this
into a spherical coordinate.
And phi is azimuthal angle.
And 0 to 90 degree
sine theta d theta--
theta is the angle,
the polar angle,
under my coordinate system.
And then I have integration over
frequency, 0 to max frequency,
and h bar omega--
so that's here--
v cosine theta--
that's vy.
And when I convert some
[INAUDIBLE] integration,
I have density of
states, D omega over 4 pi
because this D omega is
integrated originally
for 4 pi, isotropic case.
And then I have f plus--
that's the solution
I have there, here.
f plus is a function
of both mu and eta.
And then integrate
over frequency.
So that's the flux here.
And if you plug in your
solution for f eta plus,
what we have here, and
we can write it into--
so I'll give you the
final expression.
And this one, what I have
is 2 pi I0 Te1 times E3.
And this E3 is, again, the
integral exponential function
that we introduced in the
last lecture and 2 pi 0
to eta I0 eta prime and E2 eta
minus eta prime d eta prime.
So I have to, now,
introduce this I0.
I is a transformation.
So I0 is just the
integration of h bar omega
and v times D over
4 pi and f0 d omega.
So sometimes, say, this
is called intensity.
But it's just a result coming
from the simplification
in notation.
And in fact, in
photon transport,
this intensity is widely used.
But for electron and
phonon transport,
this is not widely used.
I remember when I
first wrote a paper
and submitted it Phys Review B.
And the Review had come back,
what is intensity?
And is it a scalar
or is it a vector?
And I mentioned before
this relate to f itself.
Is f itself a scalar or vector?
It has directionality.
It depends on space.
But it's scalar because it's
a scalar in the phase space.
And the directionality came
from the velocity component
in the phase space.
So this is, again,
it's a scalar.
So this is the
positive heat flux.
And you can integrate the f
minus and together [INAUDIBLE]
heat flux.
And the [INAUDIBLE] flux is
the difference of the two.
So if I write the lengthy flux--
let me write it down--
and you will gather
the [INAUDIBLE] flux
q is q plus minus q minus.
And what I have here is
2 pi and I0 Te1 E3 eta--
that's the first term--
plus what we just
wrote down, 0 to eta I0
eta prime and E2 eta minus
eta prime g eta prime.
So that's the plus term.
And then I have minus term--
minus I0 Te2 E3 and xi minus
eta minus eta to xi and I0
eta prime and E2 eta
prime minus eta d prime.
So this were the end
result after you substitute
q plus, which we derived,
and q minus, which
we didn't write down.
So this was your
[INAUDIBLE] flux.
This term come from boundary.
This term comes from boundary.
This term's coming
from internal points
the non-local part, the source,
and how much they contribute
to the [INAUDIBLE] flux,
either the location, eta,
that I'm considering.
So this one, q is a function
of eta, the different locations
along the y direction.
Yes?
AUDIENCE: How can you know
the effective temperature
distribution [INAUDIBLE]?
GANG CHEN: I don't know yet.
I didn't tell you I know.
That's what we want to find.
So this is the
complexity of solving
even the simplest [INAUDIBLE]
problem, non-local problems.
So what I'm going to next do--
this is you asked
the question-- so
how I'm going to find this out?
So my next step is to
say, to find this out,
I have to say the heat flux--
heat flux, if there is no
internal heat generation,
whether there is internal
heat generation or not.
Remember, I'm doing the
steady state problem.
You would say that,
based on the treatment,
that when I do transient,
all my analysis doesn't work.
So well, here, the
analysis is fine.
But well, my next
step is doing the--
I say there is a case when I'm
dealing with no internal heat
generation.
Now, in fact, we wrote a
paper to compare the case.
When there is the
internal heat generation,
what's the difference?
So with no internal
heat generation--
no heat generation-- and
in this case, what I have,
q is constant.
If q is constant,
I can do dq d eta
equals 0 because I don't need
to find that constant yet.
So with that, I take
this dq d eta equals 0.
I will find the equation
that actually has--
either they're eta 0 or,
say, I0 that I want to find.
So you go to take
the derivative.
Let me just repeat
here, what is the E.
En, the n-th order integral
equation equals, say,
t n minus 2 exponential
minus t over mu and d--
no, not t.
This is mu and d mu 0 to 1.
This is my integral
function of order n.
So I have E3.
And here is E2 you
can substitute in.
So if I take dq d eta equals 0,
what I have is a equation I0 T1
and E2 eta plus eta 0 Te2 and E2
xi minus eta and plus 0 to eta,
eta 0 I0 eta prime E1 eta
minus eta prime absolute d eta
prime equals 0.
I didn't go step by step.
But say when you take a
derivative, E3 becomes E2.
And the E2 becomes E1.
And these two half integral--
this is 0 to eta, eta to xi--
is combined right
into the 0 to xi.
Inside is I0 eta prime.
But E1 now has an absolute sign.
Because it changed sign
when eta equals eta prime.
So I put a absolute to
simplify the notation.
These are actually two terms.
So now, this is the
equation you need
to solve to actually find, given
the boundary condition on one
side, the Te1, on the
other side, the Te2,
and the mean free path film
thickness that determined xi.
And then you need to solve
this equation to find out
what is I0 at each point.
I0, remember, is related
to my temperature.
I0 is related to f0.
Because this is the phonon
property [INAUDIBLE]
frequency omega, which
you know from the solid
that you're dealing with.
But f0 is a function of T.
T is what I want to find.
So you really have to
solve this to find I0.
From I0, you find T.
This is the complication
of heat conduction,
non-local heat conduction.
And it's an integral equation.
And how many of you have dealt
with integral equation before?
One?
So what you need to
find is what's inside
and how to solve
integral equations.
And I can simplify
this a little bit
just to make the equation nicer.
So let me introduce a variable.
Theta is a function for eta.
And that equals
non-dimensionalized.
So I have I0 eta minus I0 Te2.
And I have here I0
Te1 minus I0 Te2.
So I introduce this
non-dimensional temperature,
or you can say it's temperature
or non-dimensional intensity
and then say it turns out there
is also non-dimensional heat
flux, which is the q, the heat
flux over pi I0 Te1 minus I0
Te2.
So this is the corresponding
non-dimensional heat flux.
And with this theta, I
can rewrite the equation.
You basically substitute this
I0 into here using the reverse
back.
And you can rewrite
the integral equation
into a more standard form.
This is what you
have is 2 theta eta
equals E2 eta plus
0 to cosine theta
eta prime and E1
eta minus eta prime.
And this is d eta prime.
So this is the integral
equation, a nicer form.
Theta-- and this is the
inside of the integrand.
And there is also non-function,
non-zero non-function.
And this is called
Fredholm integral equation
of second kind--
integral equation
of second kind.
And when I try to solve
this integral equation,
I want the numerical recipe.
And people would
teach you how to solve
this integral equations.
There's no analytical solution.
And what you have here,
E1 is often called,
this is the kernel.
That will be multiplied
to the unknown function.
And in the old days, for
this kernel, people--
when the computer
would become powerful--
before that, for
this kernel, people
would try to get an
analytical solution
by approximating kernels.
But nowadays, you can solve
this integral equation
relatively easily.
And the way to solve
the integral question
is going back to
saying if you want
to do a integral of a function,
what method do you use?
The simplest method of
doing a numerical integral
is trapezoidal method.
So whatever function this
theta is, this is my eta.
This is the unknown
function I want to find.
Let's say this is my theta eta.
And I divide this
domain into endpoint.
Say here, you can do-- the
trapezoidal is equally divided.
And for each of this trapezoid--
you take a trapezoid--
you have your area is
the width times height.
So I can do my--
approximate this integral
by discretization--
0 xi theta eta prime and E1
eta minus eta prime d eta
prime equals--
and trapezoid typically have
two ends special because it's
only half [INAUDIBLE].
So I have a theta 0 and E1 eta.
And this is a when theta prime
equals 0, so eta minus 0.
Eta itself is positive, so I
don't need the absolute sign.
Delta eta over 2.
So delta eta is the
separation of the points.
And I have, similarly, the
other end point, theta xi.
So this is when eta prime
equals this endpoint,
I have this have half
[INAUDIBLE] only.
So I have an E1, and
eta prime equals xi.
So I have xi minus eta and then
theta eta theta [INAUDIBLE]..
And then the rest is
the delta eta and 1 to n
minus one point in the center.
I have theta eta eta I--
theta I eta I E1
eta minus eta I.
So I'm discretizing eta prime.
So eta is the point
I want the find.
See, that eta, the eta, eta
is any point of this equation
is satisfied.
So this is my
discretized term here.
And then I want to
do-- if I look at this,
I have how many points
I have I want to find.
I have theta 0, theta eta, and
theta I 1 to n minus one point,
so I have n plus 1 points.
I want to find theta I eta
I equals 0, 1, 3, endpoint.
So I have total n plus 1 points.
Now, you look at the equation.
You substitute this discretized
term into a equation.
And this should be
valid for any eta point.
And then you know you need
a n equation because you--
you need an n plus 1 equation
because you have n plus 1
[INAUDIBLE].
So how you get that
n plus 1 equation?
You let your eta equals
0 delta eta, 2 delta eta,
to the total endpoint.
So you say that your
eta equals eta I. That's
the discretization point.
And then you'll get the n
plus 1 numerical equation.
And with that, you
work the matrix
to find what your theta I is.
And this matrix
is different plane
than you solve Fourier
heat conduction equation
or Navier-Stokes equation.
In that case, your
matrix is mostly 0,
except the diagonal
and the two lines
adjacent to diagonal direction.
This matrix is
typically a full matrix
because every term is non-zero.
So you need to
invert that matrix
to find the temperature
distribution or, in this case,
its non-dimensional
intensity distribution.
But there is one more trick you
put in there, one more problem.
That's this kernel.
Most of the time, when you
solve integral equation,
this kernel has a problem.
It's a singular.
And this is a case, if you
think, when you do your here,
when eta equals eta I, what
is E1 0 when eta equals eta I?
E1 0, if you look
at my definition
for the integral function
here, n equals 1, so mu and 0--
t equals 0-- so it's
a 1 over mu d mu.
So what I have is 0 to
1 on 1 over mu d mu.
1 over mu d mu log mu.
What's the value at log 0?
Blows up.
So I have a singular kernel.
And I have to deal
with that problem
when I solve integral equations.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE] doing,
like, one half [INAUDIBLE]..
GANG CHEN: Yeah, you
don't need to do that.
There is a trick to do it.
So the trick to do this one is
actually 0 to xi and theta eta
prime E1 eta minus
eta prime d eta prime.
That's what we want
to do numerically.
And what I'm going to do is
actually, I'm going to do--
because this is theta--
I'm going to subtract
this point out.
So I don't do that integration.
I do theta prime minus theta
eta E1 eta minus eta prime d eta
prime.
So this, I subtract
that theta eta.
And of course, that means I
will need to add that back.
So theta eta is not an
integration variable.
So do theta eta 0 xi E1 eta
minus eta prime d eta prime.
So this is just a equivalency.
Because this term,
I subtract, I add.
And because I'm doing
this and [INAUDIBLE]
I can plot this integral,
the kernel itself,
can be an analytically done.
And if you do this
integration, you
find that it doesn't blow up.
So that's the trick.
And this one, if you
do it, this term--
in fact, you will say this is
mu 2 minus exponential minus eta
over mu and then
minus exponential
xi minus eta over mu.
So this integral
doesn't blow up,
so I solve this
singularity problem.
And that means your
discretization,
it's a little bit more complex.
You have to write this
carefully to deal with this one.
But overall, now you have, by
incorporating those tricks,
you can solve this
integral equation.
And you have to do it
yourself to really--
there's nothing--
you all know MATLAB.
MATLAB is good at
the inverting matrix.
When I do it, I have to
write a Fortran code.
That's what I know.
But there are also libraries
to call for inverted matrix.
So this is the
trapezoidal method.
And if you use
trapezoidal method,
you need a lot of points.
For integration, trapezoidal
is the most straightforward,
but it's most inefficient.
So as I said that I'm
not a good at, really,
numerics, the coding.
But the one that I can reduce
the number of integration
I know is if I use
this quadrature method.
So if I want to use the
quadrature method fx dx,
any integration, there is
one popular quadrature--
not always good--
I equals n, say, equals 1 to n.
So this quadrature does not
divide the integration domain
uniformly.
You actually choose find
out the number of root.
In this case, I have I equals 1
to n, so n any number you take.
And it will find that the
optimal root of this quadrature
and give away.
So this is a xi.
The i-- xi--
this solution depends on
what quadrature you choose.
And how many order your n is.
And then you gave a
weight to that point.
And so a popular way is the
Gauss-Legendre quadrature.
So when I wrote
that, all my code
was written using
Gauss-Legendre quadrature.
And sometimes it works well.
Other times, it may
not be that efficient.
But there are other
quadrature you
go to look at the numerical
integration books.
And so with all this, the math
part, let's look at the result
that you are supposed to
get, look at the solution,
so what this solution look like.
So I have the
problem I'm dealing
with in the current [INAUDIBLE],,
the original configuration I
draw, this is my y direction.
And I use a
non-dimensional coordinate,
eta equals y dy mean free path.
And so if I plot the solution,
for this non-dimensionary
intensity theta
eta, and I'm going
to actually not use the eta.
Here is doubly confusing.
What I'm going to
do is y over d so
that I can plot all these
lines between 0 to 1.
d is the thickness of the plate.
So I have 0 to 1.
And this non-dimensional,
so the first is 1.
The maximum is 1.
The minimum of 0.
So one solution, this
is a Fourier solution
when the mean free path is much
smaller than the thickness.
So what I have
here, this one is xi
equals d over mean free path.
So xi is the non-dimensional
thickness or mean free path
when this one goes to infinite.
That's a thickness much larger
than the mean free path.
And this profile is linear.
And that's what you would
expect from a Fourier
law of heat conduction.
This is diffusive, the local
diffusion [INAUDIBLE] solution.
Now, in the other case,
when this xi goes to 0,
what it means there's
no scattering inside.
You will be ballistic.
So you will have
a solution flat.
It's going to 0.5.
So this is the outer
limit when xi goes to 0.
You have ballistic transport.
So why is that?
And although I say
here I'm solving
using the phonon
as example, but I
say this is valid for
electron and for molecule,
for phonon and for photon.
So let me take the
example I talked before.
This is the case when I have
radiation transfer between two
parallel plate in a vacuum.
There's no scattering
inside for photon.
Because xi is, say, goes to 0.
That means d is very small
compared to mean free path.
There's no internal scattering.
When there is no
internal scattering,
what you have here--
recall, we said that here
is sigma T1 fourth power.
Here is sigma T2 fourth power.
That's what you will get
if you do I0 integration.
Recall we did the
I0 if you put the--
for black-body radiation
integration from 0 to infinite,
you get sigma T fourth power.
That's the Stefan-Boltzmann law.
So in this case, I do not have
any scattering in between.
I do not have
equilibrium between--
very non-equilibrium.
But I'm forcing my Boltzmann
solution to get a temperature.
This temperature is the
equivalent temperature
when I have this
imaginary absorber that
absorb, on this side, absorbs
sigma T to fourth power,
on the other side absorb
sigma T1 fourth power.
So equivalently, the
absorber temperature
will be the average of this
two fourth power divided by 2.
And everywhere is the same.
So that's why you say, in this
limit, my solution is flat.
And now, in between,
I have a jump
at this continuity
at both sides.
And this will be almost
linear, not exactly.
This is where it's
in between when you
go between 0 and the infinite.
That depends on how
large is the xi.
So what's interesting out
of this is, at the boundary,
there's a temperature
discontinuity,
a temperature jump.
So this is-- originally,
this is, say, T1 is here.
That's normalized to 1.
But see, what I say here is
that inside the material, when
I use the Fourier law to find
the equivalent temperature when
there is scattering,
you want at the wall,
the temperature--
local temperature--
is different from T1.
So this temperature
discontinuity, temperature
jump, is a very tricky point.
And when we discuss chapter
5, I mentioned this.
And here, it reappear.
Because my solution
now is more general.
I can solve for any.
In the chapter 5, there's
no internal scatter,
and I see there's a jump.
That's 0.5 from 1 to 0.5.
So what I'm dealing
here is first,
it depends on what
problem you're solving.
If it's a radiation
problem, this is physical.
If a conduction problem, what
I'm talking is unphysical.
It's the wrong definition.
So why I say that?
Now, let's go back to
think about the radiation.
I mentioned this before--
here, again.
So I have this
imaginary detector.
I can put there, on one side,
it'll absorb one type of photon
as a T2 and the other side, T1.
So once I go to
the wall, it still
absorb in this side
and the other side.
And so far, I have
assumed the wall is black.
What this black means is, on
this side, a photon comes in.
They just go no reflection.
That's black.
Black is no reflection.
Everything that's
come in is absorbed.
So it's also transmission.
That means the
transmission is 1.
When transmission is 1, so
of course, this is solid.
And solid, I don't have
a way to get into it.
I put a detector.
But imagine you've got this
magical detector I have.
And if it moves
into solid but it
doesn't interact
with the phonon--
it doesn't interact
with a solid,
they only measure the
light, it's photon--
what will be the
temperature you measure?
AUDIENCE: Incoming [INAUDIBLE]?
GANG CHEN: So incoming is--
so here is here on this side
and on this side, both sides.
So it will be continuous.
In fact, there will
be no jump if you
can do that magic detector.
And of course, the
solid itself, this
photon will have absorption
and reemission in the solid.
So what will happen is that
this is what you measure.
The photon temperature
you would measure.
But there, you don't
have that detector.
What you have is a thermocouple.
And then when you
put the thermocouple
into this solid, what you
measure is a solid temperature.
That's a phonon
lattice vibration.
So this is my T1.
What I say is that this
is a phonon temperature.
And equivalently,
when they emit,
I say this is half of this
space they emit as black body.
So that's where my physical
temperature jump coming
from in the case of photon.
Now, when I do phonon and
if the surface, again,
is the black, as
what I'm seeing--
that's the [? median ?]
at the temperature T1,
equilibrium temperature.
So transmissivity is 1.
So if there's no reflection--
this is material 1, material 2,
material 3, in solid, I
typically can do multilayer
structure--
in that case, there should
really be no temperature jump.
It's similar.
You can actually
measure the temperature.
Suppose you have nice way
to measure the lattice
temperature.
So there should be no jump.
And this jump is
only because I'm
assuming the phonon coming
out is at this temperature.
What happens is that this is the
interface I discussed before.
If you look at what
comes to this side is T2,
and T1 is going out like this.
But the T2, it
goes out like this
because the lower temperature.
So if you define
temperature consistently,
you should not have that jump.
This is a highly
non-equilibrium situation.
There's no good
temperature definition.
However, the other solution--
again, you can go back
to rederive everything--
that is, when your
surface is not black,
when your surface has finite
transmission/reflection,
this is where you'll actually
have a physical temperature
discontinuity, at
the two interface.
And this wall, if you
do Boltzmann equation,
you can consistently
including everything.
And in chapter 5,
I discuss this.
It's really you
have to be careful
how you define
temperature when you
go to this ballistic or
quasi-ballistic regime.
Otherwise, you may be
comparing apple and orange.
Any questions?
It takes a lot of time.
People still continue
making those mistakes
so if you go to read papers.
And then many of them
don't distinguish
the subtle difference.
OK.
So that's a case.
So if you think
about what we talked
is a transport along
a film, transport
perpendicular to a film.
I'm going to next tell
you a story about mixture.
Now, transport them both along
and perpendicular to the film.
What would be the
case like that?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
[LAUGHTER]
GANG CHEN: This is a fluid flow.
Think about push a
fluid through a pipe,
air molecules, a small pipe.
And this is the Poiseuille flow.
So let's look at the
case, simplest case,
rarefied Poiseuille flow.
So this is the pipe flow that
you are all familiar with.
But in the limit of Poiseuille
flow, I say two parallel plate.
Between two parallel plates,
I'm flowing fluids through.
And if one plate is moving,
the other plate is stationary.
That's a Couette flow.
If it's pressure-driven,
both plates
are stationary, that's
Poiseuille flow.
You learn that in
fluid mechanics.
So I'm going to
deal with the case
where I have stationary plates.
I have a fluid flow inside.
And in this case, we wrote down
the Boltzmann equation df dx.
This is my x direction.
And my y vy df dy equals
f minus fd over tau.
That's my relaxation time.
And it's not the f0 because I
have a non-zero fluid velocity,
average velocity.
So it is displaced Maxwell
distribution, we said before.
So this displaced
Maxwell distribution
is n m 2 pi kBT 3 over 2
exponential m v. That's
the random velocity minus
u, which is a function.
In the case of laminar flow--
it's 2-- u is a function only--
u is changing in the x direction
but is a function of y.
That's the pi flow
in normal parabola.
And y is my coordinate.
U is the flow, average
flow direction.
So u is a function of y
but is in the x direction.
So flow is in the x direction.
My constraint is, again,
in the y direction.
That's a finite thickness.
And it's pressure-driven.
So where does the
pressure come in?
It doesn't come into
my Boltzmann equation.
Pressure, in fact, is
a statistical average,
just like temperature is
mechanical-- statistical
average on the momentum.
But in this case here, it can
relate to n is a function of x.
And then you can use the
ideal gas as PV equals nRT.
So this is-- you relate
this molecular density
to the pressure.
I have to say that
I'm not satisfied
with this approximation.
So ideally, I would
not even do that.
I would say, OK, my pressure
is just a momentum average.
I tried to do that, and
I was not successful.
So this is the classical.
You'll put in the
Boltzmann equation now.
And both in the x
direction have u in x.
I have the source term in
the x direction-- pressure.
And in the y direction,
I have the boundary.
And if you plug in
into the equation,
you will find out
that you need to do
the same thing as we did for
the perpendicular transport.
Because u, that's a
velocity distribution
is we do not know-- average
velocity distribution,
just like when you try to find
temperature distribution. u is
a function of y.
And so u is inside the integral.
It's an integral
equation over u.
When you do
everything derivable,
just follow the same way.
So what is interesting
is out of this problem
is a Knudsen minimum.
So this was observed
experimentally
in 1905 or 1906, this
period, by Knudsen
doing rarefied gas flow.
And what they observed
is if you plot your flux,
say, mass flux,
which is normalized,
say, 2R ideal gas constant
0 and the d square--
d is the thickness
of the plate--
and the real measure
the flux and dp dx.
And so this is a
non-dimensional.
And what it has is--
and this is drawn as a
function of Knudsen number,
which is a [INAUDIBLE].
Knudsen number is a
mean free path over d.
That xi, I mentioned before,
is d over mean free path.
In different fields,
there are different names.
For example, inverse
of this is, in optics,
called optical thickness.
In acoustic, we also
call acoustic thickness.
But this inverse, mean free
path over d is a Knudsen number.
And that's why it has
a longest history.
So if you say Knudsen number
for phonon, Knudsen number
for electron, that's all fine.
You just need to follow
the same mean free path
over the thickness, over
the [INAUDIBLE] thickness.
There are people actually
call the wrong inverse
as the Knudsen number.
That's wrong.
So what they find experimentally
is that it goes this way.
And this is the 1.
This is about 1.
This is what happens
around the 1.
And when you go to--
so here, very small
Knudsen number.
That's a continuum.
Very large Knudsen number,
that's a rarefied gas flow.
And in between,
there is a minimum.
And this minimum called
the Knudsen minimum.
This was experimentally
found, though.
So I say, around 1900,
that there was no solution.
People try to do approximate
solution Boltzmann equation.
And it wasn't really
until 1960 or 1950,
and there is a
great mathematician,
and he solved the problem.
Cercignani, he solved this
problem, Boltzmann equation
this way I just written
down, like y direction,
and you'll find the velocity.
And they found that,
indeed, this solution
has a Knudsen minimum.
And the reason for
this, I tried to come up
with a very direct picture.
And the reason is this.
You have a pressure-driven
flux going in the x direction.
And then we say in
heat conduction,
the roughness always decrease
the thermal conductivity.
But see, here, actually,
you got a regime
where in the very dilute regime,
your pressure is pressing
these fluids much faster.
So the boundary
effect is actually,
the scattering at the
boundary, is less important.
And that's why you have
the recovery of this, say,
flux, the fluid mass flux there.
And then, corresponding
to this solution,
you go to look at your velocity
distribution in the pipe
or in the parallel plate.
You'll actually find-- this
is where the name actually
come from.
We know that, typically,
when we do fluid problem,
you see velocity is a
non-slip boundary condition.
But the Boltzmann equation
will tell you-- actually,
this is 0--
the velocity has a
discontinuity at the wall.
So this is the velocity.
There is actually slip happen
between the fluid and the wall.
So this is the
slip, velocity slip.
And in the next
lecture, we'll actually
discuss people have
tried to [INAUDIBLE]..
Obviously, if you do
rarefy flow or you
do fluid mechanics
and micro fluids,
you'll add artificial
velocity slip.
And in fact, you add the
first-order and second-order
velocity slip to
try to accommodate.
It turns out that the
first-order velocity
slip typically can
go to this regime.
It cannot go, say, Knudsen
equals 1 or you want higher.
Second-order velocity
slip, you will overpredict
the velocities, they Knudsen--
this range.
So even those states, there
are people still trying
to write the boundary condition.
And I'll tell you a story how I
derive a new boundary condition
next lecture.
But this is the Knudsen flow
and the rarefied Poiseuille flow
Knudsen minimum.
And let me tell you a story.
I mentioned many times
that the disk drive,
the disk drive industry.
And the disk drive is
a lubrication problem.
So what it has is
this is a disk.
Lubrication problem is
typical [INAUDIBLE] equation.
And the [INAUDIBLE]
question, how it is
is basically the rotating disk.
Here's the magnetic head.
And this magnetic head
has an inclination.
So it's like an airplane.
You have angle, so
that gives you lift.
And the lift is very important.
Because otherwise, your
header will crash the disk.
And this disk will
rotate about 10,000 RPM--
very fast.
So about 10 years
ago, I have a friend.
They said, can you
look at this problem?
We have 1 nanometer separation
that we cannot predict.
And that 1 nanometer,
they already--
[INAUDIBLE] they have
not used the continuum.
They actually use the Boltzmann
equation solution for the flux.
So they used
Cercignani's solution.
Because this problem is,
so you're stationary.
So you can roughly say
this is your moment plane.
It's a combination of the two.
It's pressure.
Because when you have an angle--
if you don't have an angle,
that's a Couette flow.
When you have an angle, you have
a pressure difference build up.
So the pressure were
Poiseuille flow.
So it's a superposition
of Couette
and the Poiseuille flow.
So they have been using
the Cercignani solution.
And there was a famous paper
for this disk drive problem
that decomposing.
But they say there is
a 1-nanometer problem.
I said, what cares?
1 nanometer-- why you need it?
It turns out that because,
at the time I mentioned,
they were about 20
nanometer flying height.
And now this flying height
I mentioned also to you
is about 1.5 nanometer.
OK, that's why it's such
an important problem.
We'll never find out,
though, what's the reason.
It could be the molecular.
It could be absorb the molecule.
It could be the molecular
[INAUDIBLE] size of molecules.
But it's a very relevant
technology problem.
And nowadays, like
I say, there's
still concern because
you still have disk,
and you have a slider there.
And finally, there
is another problem.
You can think about this.
If I have T hot and T cold,
I have a small opening.
So this opening is smaller
than molecular mean free path.
The question is, what's
the flux direction?
What's the mass flux going,
from cold to hot or hot to cold?
Maybe we'll discuss
in the next lecture.
You can think about this.
I'll ask you at the beginning.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
GANG CHEN: Huh?
GANG CHEN: I want
the [INAUDIBLE] flux.